[Music]
subject for today
[Music]
[Applause]
a nice little christmas wreath thank you
where is the christmas oh yeah yeah
we have several christmas also commit
felonies because apparently you're
supposed to avoid getting
sick by uh spending christmas outside
socially distanced
in december i think i think he's safe
avoid the kavid catch actual pneumonia
yes
just skip right over to it yeah it makes
it easier we have a lot that we will be
talking about today by the way there was
the hearing of course in michigan
yesterday so we're going to be recapping
that
uh cnn now acknowledges that uh
china-lined people died
really on the wuhan about time it's
almost like we covered it beforehand and
we have some charts and graphs for you
which will be a lot of fun
and they act like they have they act
like they have a scoop now yeah yeah all
right big capper breaking news yeah
china is a dishonest country wow
so we talking about that we what else
are we talking about oh the usps uh that
yeah
it's postal workers the uh
whistleblowers apparently hundreds of
thousands of ballots were part of it it
was basically you know
replace newman and cramer's uh bottle
return scheme to michigan only make it
ballots from new york to pennsylvania to
the tune of hundreds of thousands
oh wow don't try and cool your radiator
with blood so we also have quarter black
garrett appreciate it he is accepted
amongst no communities i'm sorry
three quarters of a home and gerald a is
here how are you sir i am well how are
you
uh i'm not great no we're gonna be
shooting brendan today though testing
you feel better that'll be a lot of fun
yeah just a lot of stuff happening in
the news that i'm not happy about
well of course this is actually
happening right now this just broke here
this morning because everyone's been
you guys have been uh following the bar
yeah i was about to say bob barr that's
the libertarian
that's a different different thing no
one cares about
[Applause]
bill barr um people have been saying
that he's saying oh there's absolutely
no evidence in the in that uh the the
investigate people like oh there you go
it's over
actually no there was a statement issued
from the doj today they fired back
specifically at news reports and they
said
some media outlets have incorrectly
reported that the department has
concluded its investigation of election
fraud and announced an affirmative
finding of no fraud in the election
that is not what the associated press
reported nor what the attorney general
stated
the department will continue to receive
and vigorously pursue
all specific and credible allegations of
fraud well that sounds like an open
showcase to me yes
what about the times where he
specifically said no collusion
right they didn't exactly run with that
no right so the news is lying to us
is what you're saying i don't know if
they're lying so much as they are just
completely incompetent
um i think it's worse than that which
hey by the way we are going to be
testing today again youtube's algorithms
these uh this
this this month because things have
changed on youtube and all of a sudden
things are a little bit screwy so
comment right now comment just comment
right now if you're watching you can't
do it live
watching the archive comment we're going
to do an ask me anything favorite color
my childhood upbringing whatever you
want all of these subjects just comment
if you can't think of anything to
comment comment
test but let's beat the algorithm
biden uh uh not president-elect biden
has talked about one of his first
actions uh priorities
okay his first day in office in relation
to
um gender policy and you know what not a
moment too soon here's chuck schumer
talking about it
joe biden said that on his first day of
office he will give
transgender students access to sports
bathrooms and locker rooms in accordance
with their gender identity in all
federally funded schools
do you think he has the ability to do
this and do you agree with this decision
i agree with the decision and i know
he'll check things out thoroughly
legally
he will check things out the good old
scratch and sniff
yeah that's pedophiles checking things
out as well
this could not have happened at a more
important time
because um ellen page of course has many
of you have been following but there's
more to the story than people know ellen
page most
known for her roles in uh juno inception
uh x-men three the remake of flatliners
oh that's right that's right
sorry catalog ellen page beloved actress
of the united states right
is now a man
you can hit the overlay there yeah i
don't have to direct this all day
it's now a man oh so the privilege card
is now removed came out as
elliott by the way ellen page is now
elliott
page just listen just be ready for the
attacks because as a straight white
male you are given no quarter
[Laughter]
and we actually this is something that's
been uh a long time coming and here at
laravel county we actually have the
exclusive
of uh the upcoming first performance of
uh elliot page
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'll be watching that's just that's the
elf theme song
i got the yeah well it you just mix it
that's very good so whatever happens
oh boy that's one person i don't want to
munch
talk about
i got the biggest eye roll from my wife
when i showed her that last night
because we watched the umbrella academy
and she's like is there ever a role that
that formerly ellen was in that
she didn't look like a like a well pouty
guy anyway
that's that's uh in poor taste well
sorry it's ellie
this is almost crazy to me is when
comedians go along with us and i'll
explain to you why this is a
people why are you talking about the
transgender well first off i think we've
done a pretty fair job of covering
election fraud i think i've been pretty
consistent
and this does matter people say why do
you talk about something that doesn't
affect you
um the breakdown of the idea of men and
women affects
everybody yes notably children like why
do you care about what hitler's doing
with the jews if it doesn't affect you
well it doesn't affect me but
the jews aren't big fans of it what
about the children
who only taught that men and uh women
and male female are just a figment of
your imagination
that's a problem well and how long until
we get the european bug and say well you
can't say anything against these people
or it's a year in jail like we reported
yesterday
speaking of bugs uh this guy i think
he's very funny i'm surprised that
comedians
come out and support us
from silicon valley a very funny guy he
said this is an actual tweet
i've been a fan of elliot's for a very
long time and
i'm excited to see him continue his
fantastic work
in the years to come fantastic fan of
elliot his work
i believe is uh quarter black garrett
yeah
yeah oh wait what you're saying i got
skipped up i can see
yeah you did uh no apparently uh elliott
uh paige has just as many film credits
as caitlyn jenner has medals so
oh wow this is the course i understand
the slippery slope like a bunch
for crying out loud that you have now
made every single casting director who's
issued character breakdowns guilty of
hate speech
you've retroactively made people guilty
of hate speech
yeah so do we refer to
elliott in the like past now when
referring to past roles
netflix changed the credits did they
really yeah oh my gosh
that's the cast an elliot page type
oh my gosh i love it i don't love it no
no that was sarcastic out of your mind
i'm gonna kill you are you out of your
mind what is this hanging with him he's
just always telling me
he's going to kill me he doesn't do show
prep so it's like i know what my i'll
say i'll kill you
murder yeah that's murder this works
that's a family-friendly activity yeah
off the top of the shore are you off
your hormone blockers no
they wouldn't refill the prescription
[Laughter]
take on an empty stomach
[Laughter]
[Music]
small meal small meal or crackers
they also stop brain development by the
way those hormones
[Laughter]
that when you actually look at
neurotransmitters and hormones are very
similar and interact at a very important
level just look at thyroid look at
testosterone
look at how that affects dopamine
serotonin it's almost as though these
things actually matter but i know i know
the science isn't in
you'll you'll walk the wide perimeter
six feet mind you at whole foods to
avoid bpa
in anything uh regarding plastic or any
kind of container because you don't want
something mimicking estrogen in the body
when
injected directly into your ass cheek
however for a six-year-old oh you know
we're a little murky on the science
i understand that
you have to have a conversation with
your kid now about this yeah right
they have the right to demand this by
the way by the way i'm sorry i'm sorry
sweetheart
your mom was guilty of hate speech i you
know i uh that
i will say looking back you're gonna
have people now too retroactively
reviewing films looking back
the remake of flatliners didn't make me
want to swallow a knife
i didn't find it disrespectful to the
art of cinema
because of the beautiful and brave
elliot
the fact that this is the only show the
fact is the only show where
my immediately went to e.t dressed as a
transgender alien that i said to elliot
and i didn't see it anywhere that's the
only show that could think about it and
do it
so you won't see it as easy you won't
see that on uh any conan this is uh this
ain't no
family matters they're too scary that's
a tuxedo it's your heart out
oh no don't bring that back don't bring
it it's grown on me
she's using it now it's growing on me
before we move on uh
please do consider going to the merch
store actually lettucecuttershop.com we
have uh some discounts here for people
who are shopping uh for christmas
looking for christmas gifts have those
christmas gifts uh or a blank screen if
you like it yeah the best gift the dark
screen if you like
do consider joining us at louder.com
that's what allows us to continue leave
a comment we'll be taking your live chat
after this and man you'll be doing a
police sketch
yeah nice so someone he doesn't know yet
oh that's true uh
so this is something we need to talk is
the michigan hearing and i'm getting
tired of the hearings and listen this is
the goal of the media is for you all to
be fatigued
i was like which state now there's a
selection from okay is it pennsylvania
is it michigan is it wisconsin or is it
georgia or is it arizona pick a lane the
answer is
yes right and it makes sense that
the stuff that would come out later
would be bigger or at least
more reliable than the stuff that was
just sort of suspected early on it's
almost it's getting worse it's almost
like building um a
national case takes more than two weeks
yeah oh oh come on there's nothing yet
it's almost like going to the supreme
court requires more than a couple
interns in a pdf file
and a space bar get on the line with
tucker
i sydney it i don't i just remember you
don't see the left doing this them
cannibalizing themselves and i can't i
can't believe that you didn't give me
this exclusive
you mean you mean the case that i'm
building and if i don't have everything
right i could be under threat of
being cuffed yeah no no i'm sorry by the
way
you don't work with a bow tie or no bow
tie bow tie no bow tie it's not a good
show i'm not gonna wear exclusively
cnn cnn takes like three days to fire
somebody who was caught doing something
inappropriate on the zoom call
cnn takes nine months to acknowledge
that china the chinese government is
filled with communist liars
so my question to you is are we talking
about that do you believe
that cnn didn't know that cnn actually
believed china or do you think they were
in on it like the member of the world
health organization on a skype call who
slam-dunked the taiwanese like it was
his grandmother and he couldn't hear he
pulled the whole ruffle
uh ruffled the chip bag i can't hear
your grandma i'm going out
yeah they never covered it on cnn right
doesn't that matter
especially considering there's some
isn't there some kind of a history with
taiwan
and uh china little i don't know all
right it's like the china is [ __ ] guy
china is actually they should have
listened to that guy well yeah best
reporting we've seen from china
i know all the information by the way he
now is a woman
you know him you have to allow me this
opportunity to apologize yes
yes i also apologize for saying that
bruce jenner won gold medals
no listen caitlyn jenner never want to
go metal kate and jenner hit
people with his car her her car her
car it's confusing i know how funny
would it be if ellen page just now just
smokes frankie munoz in a drag race whoa
shouldn't have so many strokes was it
was it heart attacks what was it that
that frankie municipality
apparently is an accomplished race car
driver but we all know once you switch
genders
you don't the driving is the first thing
that comes it goes
so the michigan hearings took place yeah
no when it comes when you're
coming in and you get to drive yeah
[Laughter]
yeah what is happening i mean
screwdrivers were sounded like a good
idea yeah
early in the morning wait hold on a
second cnn really quickly before we go
to the hearings
la county shatters record and worst day
of penn
i thought you had to walk down what
happened
the harshest of lockdowns yeah what
happened there
oh those are cases what about deaths i
want to get the benefit for the day it's
probably john mcarthur's fault right
yeah it's all yes absolutely all the
churches i blame desantis
it's the crips going around and giving
all their victims covet so they don't
get blamed
all those ass hats rollerblading down in
daytona
how much is a life worth inline skating
has any can anyone make look i want you
to look can anyone make a case to me
that lockdowns have worked at all any
kind of
statistical causation there that
lockdown's about any effect can anyone
out there anyone
give me that argument nope europe united
states any of the states
1918 military time award didn't happen
then either
i know i hate science but you know i'm
open to it right now
um so the michigan hearings did happen
they started uh well they didn't start
yesterday but yesterday
uh there was a hearing and it started
with possibly my new
favorite person uh oh yeah this was
i we have a lot to get but this was just
fun welcome to the senate oversight
committee you have three minutes thank
you committee i am so happy to be here
let me put my hat back on because this
is my prize right here this is the
winner who won the election before it
was cheated
and um uh as a sidebar for senator um
santana welcome my sister from the d
if black lives matter why did you skip
me
well let me tell you it was voter fraud
at its finest pure and
calculated fraud and i wouldn't be
surprised the people up here was
involved
let me grab my hat but before i speak
how do y'all feel about
force side of me i appreciate it
bringing her hand sanitizer oh that's ky
get ready
get ready they were not prepared for
that
she had jessie jackson rhyming and
everything yeah she did
a black lesbian because i could get away
with anything as much as you want not
that she's a lesbian no no no no no no
but she still gets away with more than i
do
or or elliot page will be able to
believe it or not but alan's not home
um it's going to switch back be like
screw this
this is too hard you know it's also not
home when you're home on blockers
dopamine pleasure
that neuroship has sailed
it's dark don't worry we'll talk about
that we'll talk about mental health when
a celebrity commits suicide
yeah we'll talk about antidepressants
and hormones and the correlation
not when we're trying to make sure that
uh you know you're jailed for hate
speech if you say that a man is a man
it's not gmos yeah um
we'll go through the hearings here uh
here's there are a few claims that are
new and there are some that obviously
are um
sort of repeated claims that we've
already verified here on this program
but there were some new ones and it's
hard to keep track
i do this for a living and it's very
hard for me to keep track so i'm going
to try and simplify it distill it as
well as i can for you there was one
witness who said that
military ballots she saw they looked
like xerox copies these were military
ballots
they looked like xerox copies of each
other meaning multiple of the same
ballot
um none of them were registered michigan
voters and uh i don't know if you know
this but again we've noticed a
disturbing trend with these mistakes
i know you're thinking well okay but
that's so you so you doubled up on votes
but if it ends up being a
you know okay an extra 50 for buy an
extra 50 for no hold on end phrase
only for biden here you go now one of
the military ballots
was a registered voter um and the
ballots looked like they were all
exactly the same xerox copies of the
ballot they were all for biden across
the board there wasn't a single trump
vote
and none of the the voters were
registered they had to manually enter
the names and addresses and a birth date
of 1
1 2020 which would override the system
and allow them to enter
non-registered voters of which i saw
several that day
throughout the day that's how they would
override voters that were neither in the
electronic
poll book or the supplemental updated
poll book wow okay
you know what's so sinister about this
and i know people will watch right now
with a skeptic and you should watch this
with a skeptical mind all of these
sources will be available at
louderathcrider.com you just click the
description we try to make these
available to you they will say well look
that's just that's just hearsay
as though it's like christine blasey
ford saying that she was raped at a
party that
happened in a house that doesn't exist
it's not now what you have are signed
affidavits and you have people under
threat of
under penalty of perjury making these
claims you go where's the paper trail
that's why we need a hand audit whoa we
can't because we don't have enough
evidence we're trying to get to it
that's why you have hundreds of people
saying we saw it we saw it we need to
confirm it and they're trying to seize
voting machines
there is no amount of proof that will
allow the left to say okay you know what
let's just
let's recount this why don't you just do
an audit verify
you do it this all goes away this all
goes away
you will not hear a peep from me cross
my heart and hope to die
yeah and why in the world would they
allow a ballot that has
an 11 month old birthday on it it's like
that
is that overwhelming military i guess
we're a little
murky on the rulebook as to when life
begins yeah
yeah that's right if they're voting
straight ticket democrats
boy just keep that that one survive the
abortion keep it in the incubator for
another
one's election four months four months
we'll uh we'll get that just one
this is a little paw there let me do it
okay
good thank you yeah and throw out every
single ballot that has
one one 20 20 as the i'm sorry it's
insane you did it not us right
it's not our fault that you cheated so
this is the point the whole point is
every one of these
instances needs to be investigated and
either proven to be
completely false so that we can all
point and laugh and go yeah you guys are
idiots for saying that right or
proven that something did happen that
needs to be
undone right why is that controversial
well they will say well listen it's not
our br
and i understand this the burden of
proof is not on me to prove innocence
well first of all that's for an
individual
right at this case at this point in this
case there's far more evidence than for
example
russia collusion you were saying prove
an absence of okay and
it was in this case there have been no
steps to verify it all the closest we
have is a recount of the exact same
machine
in georgia which wouldn't reveal any of
this info you you wouldn't be able to
confirm
affidavits if you did that recount of
the machine and by the way
they still found 5500 more votes right i
don't even know how that happens
i don't either but here's the thing they
are on the hook for making sure this
election if you have reason to believe
that there was
fraud in this election and you sign your
name certifying the results
of that election there's a lot of people
out there right now that think that
might be illegal
yes right so you do have a
responsibility to make sure that these
instances it's not us to pay for an
audit
this is absolutely worth looking into it
by the way
they're talking about this uh jimmy
bruschetta there on cnn look they're
saying
georgia's secretary of state second
recount sees no major changes so far
well of course you couldn't recap they
didn't check the signatures
yeah they're not doing what they're
being asked to do let's say this do you
guys use a scantron still in school
no did you guys use a scantron yeah
number two pencil my scan was i used to
deliberately use a non-number two pencil
get myself some extra days to study be
like oh the test didn't work
why you should have said number two we
did say number two we said it in the
handout that we sent home with you and
again before the test well at that point
it's too late they say it constantly are
there other pencils i didn't even know
there was another pencil
i don't know but it seems like number
two is a pretty dominating shape yeah
you got a monopoly
but if they said if they said uh
scantrons for example i said oh you know
what this this isn't accurate it misread
your actual test score here
oh what did it say it said you have an
85 and i'm looking at five or six wrong
answers well you know what just run that
again through the scantron machine but
still says 85. no but i'm saying that
the machine isn't right
yeah good enough for me yeah we can't
that's the georgia recount just to be
clear it's not an actual recount there
is no canvassing there is no hand
counting so
there are affidavits we do have some
evidence by the way statistical evidence
and there is some evidence of internet
being connected to the machine the
machine
connection hard lined by the way what is
this 1998
yeah it's still ethernet cable and then
you
have to have an investigation so you can
verify these claims
of which there are hundreds in multiple
states and there are several
claims to each act of fraud that's the
thing right
that you wouldn't be able to have this
these many people confirming these
levels of fraud across the country in
different states
maybe you would i can't say you wouldn't
it's very unlikely right
it's it's less likely than china telling
the truth on
kovid but somehow that got past cnn
their fact checkers were busy so here's
another one another witness said that
the dominion voting machines um and
we've talked about this yesterday but
this is another person saying
that they were connected to the internet
when i got down there on the morning of
the fourth i went back for an
additional day because i witnessed so
many irregularities when i was there on
election day on the third
immediately upon walking in i ran into
uh randy bishop
and randy owns radio stations he's very
i.t savvy he said brian
i was here all night what what's going
on here is unbelievable he said let me
show you something
right now before i leave so he walked me
over to the high speed scanners and
tabulators and he said see all these
ethernet lines running out of the
tabulators they're all bundled together
as they accumulate and then they're all
connected to these routers
and then they all go to the main
computer he said these are all hooked
into the internet
and that is illegal and it should not be
happening because it opens them up to
hacking
isn't it weird when a witness has to
tell people there that something's
illegal
a little bit your honor that's illegal
[ __ ]
which is sure right that means bad
couldn't a five-year-old spot an
ethernet cable do you have to be an
i.t expert to point this out that this
little line running from the machine
connecting to a router is going to the
internet can we get some 11 months here
11 month old poll watchers looking for
ethernet cables
can we do that it seems like it seems
like there's
just a pandemic of 11 month old voters
just put them on
poll watching duty yeah give them
something ethernet cable specialist
i'm sorry sir you have to go home
because of pipe burst
i know we're disappointed about it as
well on your way now
it crawls out most secure election in
modern american history yes yeah we
talked about this
yesterday by the way poll challenger uh
and uh so this was a dominion contract
um we talked about that people had
previously testified that
they were connected to the internet and
they talked about how they were
connected to
wi-fi and how this was going out uh uh
to frankfurt there are these connections
that people had access to it that
foreign actors could absolutely have
access to it and there was information
that was being distributed
to foreign actors now i'm saying these
are the allegations these are the claims
and there have been receipts
brought you cannot claim that it is the
most fair and secure election of all
time
if it's connected to wi-fi without a
password yeah
i mean you can if you're going on 60
minutes on sunday
i don't do that with my roku because i
have a cheap
neighbor who won't pay for netflix oh
jerk well saying it was a safe and
secure election is also a positive claim
that right has a burden of proof too
right right so they have they have to do
that
as much as they don't stand up for they
never stand up under scrutiny right
it's the safest it's the safest and most
secure election of modern american
history
uh question yes you in the back what if
someone has access to a radio shack well
then it's out of our hands
you imagine going to like the police and
saying yeah there's this guy over there
he's got a
severed head in his yard that's not
enough evidence for us to come over
there but really you should well
are you going to pay for this are you
going to pay for us to come and
investigate this potential
crime like do you have a separate head
in your yard no well is that why you've
got mine
i know a guy gerald yeah
he knows himself i know my man i'm
looking at the man
in the mirror not anymore by the way hit
the notification bell if you're
subscribed on youtube because uh your
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot on
youtube and by that i mean
they mean nothing nothing at all
weekdays 10 a.m you can watch us here
um here's another one um i don't know if
you remember this the day after the
election so we'll go back to when we
were covering this
this was after uh in uh uh i believe an
hour and a half nap
yeah i was still sleeping you weren't
that's were you here no you weren't here
then no no no no not the morning
the morning anyway right he wasn't here
the morning after we had courtney
you and then half asian bill came in a
little bit later yeah yeah with some of
this exclusive
because we stopped election night
because they said they're going to stop
counting and we're going to stop
counting there's nothing we can do here
there's nothing what we're going to do
speculate like it's a cable news show
that's valueless
so we decided to go home get a little
beauty sleep
proof is in the pudding or not namely
that my face
looks like pudding
oh no it doesn't oh stop it don't don't
don't don't ruin myself
it's more of a congealed
so after the election we were covering
this again in real this is something
that we have that nobody else out there
could have because you had people who
covered the election live and then you
have commentators afterward
we were the same people aside from it
gerald not withstanding no we don't
expect you to do 19 hours of streaming i
get it
um we were covering it that night came
back an hour and a half later
and there was all of a sudden this dump
of votes that changed the election
here's a trip down memory lane it's the
dead of night
the polls have been closed for hours and
hours where are these bad where are
these and they were supposed to stop
counting that's what they said
on air think of the different points
here where there's no security
there's no security first off we have no
idea how these things got into the van
there's no one there right now escorting
him from the van
wild conspiracy theory centering on
ballot counting in detroit is going
viral tonight
without evidence she suggests that what
she's recording
is someone delivering thousands of
ballots in the middle of the night
right around the time michigan went from
trump to biden
sorel even did an interview about it
with a conservative radio host
it looks like it was caring as it is now
equipment for our crews who were working
long hours here yesterday
right so that was our coverage and then
their coverage of our coverage
um this isn't this isn't on radio
yeah it's almost like you can't trust
them
we don't know what youtube is it's radio
it even appears not a conservative radio
show
no that's not it no it's radio with
video they run a clip of tucker carlson
even appeared
on uh on a public cable access program
in schenectady no that's
well my mistake there's no fixing it now
how about you fire everyone yeah
i don't know if you know how radio works
but it doesn't usually have video with
it
oh no it's a new radio new record
um and so that's what we were covering
the day of 4 a.m that happened and the
election changed and
again you see in the michigan hearings
yesterday this is confirmed by several
witnesses
uh who confirmed that uh i want to be
what's the name of the wagons that they
call it red flyer what is this radio
flight
radio radio flyer so there were coolers
coming and this is what the media does
with their selective fact checks
there were coolers coming in there was
the red radio flash that was called
radio flyer weather players and we saw
what they're just bringing ballots in
what the media did they fact checked
they said ah they were putting camera
equipment in the wagon first off
uh i uh transport camera equipment um
i pay for the equipment that you see
here it's kind of expensive kind of a
biggie so i try and keep it pretty
there's no way to protect it in a wagon
it just rocks around there's no possible
it's like hey can i guarantee that these
four thousand dollar lenses are
never usable once again let me put it so
they fact check oh
the wagon had camera equipment well what
about all the coolers well we haven't
investigated that
do it that's your job well hold on what
was in the coolers we assume
more cameras you can't fit in that
cooler what what exactly were they
preparing to record at 4am that they
needed additional camera equipment
oh no no no okay so let me be really
clear about this i misspoke they were
planning on using the cameras to knock
people unconscious with them okay well
that's that's not listed in the uses
namely 11 month old poll watchers
they're very easy to knock unconscious
soft heads
as we were watching this we were saying
what is this what is going on this is a
this is a weird process and we're
pointing out the security this is
exactly what this is we're saying this
is
a poorly poorly handled security so
either way these things shouldn't be
allowed to go in
completely unchecked with no security in
and out the front door back door that's
what we were talking about it was
it was unraveling before our eyes we
were watching it play out and they fact
check well it turns out the wagon just
had a couple of cannons we're like
look at canada's cameraman right here
had a couple of nokias well what about
the rest of it well you know what we
have to move on to something else we're
pretty busy did you hear about elliott
page
trending number one so um this was
confirmed
uh after reporting that there were 84
boxes 600 ballots each 50
000 votes let's go to the hearing clip i
also saw
the the ballots being dropped off about
i don't know three three thirty four
o'clock in the morning four o'clock 3 30
i think i've heard four o'clock
um is by my estimation there was a
delivery i would estimate
because the table in the center next to
the main stage is where the
ballots were brought to somewhere at
least 60 boxes were brought in
i see a truck at the loading dock
coming in the back of the tcf center and
by the time i
looked mr baxter and his management team
were
personally holding in boxes and carrying
them in i'm looking at these numbers
here 84
boxes 600 each in each box over 50 000
ballots
where did these ballots go they were
just
processed isn't it weird that again this
witness testimony they're bringing
information
that you think the people in charge of
the election should know right away
right i would estimate uh i don't know
50 boxes they should be able to go right
oh at that time was it 452 we can tell
you exactly how many votes and how many
boxes
no idea and where they came from no idea
santa's christmas list of naughty and
nice
is more effective think about that first
yeah they didn't even check it once
right if someone came in and said hey
you know what uh you're guilty and this
is let's say let's say youtube or
facebook came in and said hey you know
what you're guilty of hate speech
because you said that uh
elliot page was at was at one point a
woman or you said that
a female was in the film the pregnant
female in juneau was a woman right and
they say
that you're guilty of hate speech i said
really where do they say this they say
somewhere around uh
in the first oh hold on you're talking
about uh ellen page the wonderful
actress who i actually really liked and
remains to be seen what happens with
elliott page yeah we can find that at
four minutes and 33 seconds why because
it's my show
i'm in charge of it we've got the
records but imagine if someone else has
to come in and give me time codes to
my program yeah you're in charge of the
election well that's outside of my
purview
what is in your purview harold yeah oh
and what happened next
yeah that's right and this is what
you're calling the safest and securest
yeah most every i don't
like it when the people who are in
charge of elections are sitting at
rap detention because the curiosity gap
is so incredible
due to eyewitness testimony like well we
saw these
votes these pallets coming in and
coolers yes yeah
fascinating oh fascinating
tell me more captain and that's all for
today kids
oh oh no i want to go come on the
anticipation is killing me
i hope it'll last but i mean
this shouldn't be news to anyone just
like it shouldn't be news to you cnn
that
china lies about everything not all
chinese just the government
yeah by the way they're doing a great
job of not covering a
single hearing by the way i don't know
if you've been watching cnn lately
not not one well only when i'm on this
show yeah and
i feel like uh if i need to work up the
nerve to put a shotgun in my mouth
yeah that's harder yeah i'm like well i
don't know i'm like i don't want this to
be a cry for help
i just i you know i just you know this
is this is this is a real one
i put on cnn when you think i'm not
depressed enough yeah yeah yeah and then
you tape your eyes open
you know and talk smith just doesn't cut
it anymore i gotta put on stelter
like a loop like a morphine drip and
just
watch the screen at wrapped attention
and then one of these days
so oh jeez it's so dark you're
you've been threatening murder all day
that's true at least
victimless crime you just haven't
committed
i'm a coward
it's really dark wow that's what people
say this is very very dark
i'm not nick to polly you guys you
listen to this victor paulie goes people
always say
suicide is so credit to nick the police
one of them because people always say
suicide is cowardly
because really no listen somebody how
many of you out there said oh i want to
kill myself right now but you don't
because you're a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
sounds like so here's another claim that
was made at the things uh
a dominion contractor oh it's getting
interesting melissa
carone caroni um said that there are
batches of ballots again this is a claim
that's been made several times will be
easily dis
you could easily disprove it if you just
actually counted these ballots
if you actually accessed the machines
and went through the hand ballots and
properly addressed the secrecy envelopes
right if you did that
you'd be able to dispel all of this hey
let's assume it's
none of it's true but at a certain point
when you have hundreds
of people i don't know if it's over
thousands now who are coming forward
saying it's true
just make it go just make it go away she
said eight
to ten times these batches of ballots
are being counted
there was batches of ballots being ran
through the tabulating machines
numerous times um being counted eight to
ten times
at least ninety percent of those workers
were all in on this there was not
a single ballot the whole night the
whole 27 hours i was there
that i saw that was for donald trump not
one
wow take michigan helen and bottom
carter's word for it yeah
some balance maybe hidden in her hair 27
hours yeah and not a single trumpo ah
they just don't like him no no nothing
nothing nothing to see i'm sorry
i'm sorry launch into conspiracy
theories
statistical anomalies i think you could
travel back in time in a delorean to
stalin's russia
and you still wouldn't be able to go 27
hours without finding
yeah come on they would look at this and
be like really good come on
and i don't mean the citizens because
you certainly would find a lot of trump
i mean stalin's own personal team
yeah stalin himself accidentally
even chavez is watching this going like
listen you got to
you got to throw him off the center yes
you know a few people disappeared tell
them they stuck to you if it's cold up
there in dc television
they're talking to a telephone pole
they're not around anymore
and then count the votes i mean be
realistic
wow so blatant maybe eventually they'll
investigate
who knows and keep in mind this is again
corroborated by
other people um in michigan yeah
affidavits i think we have this in the
michigan brief it's page
uh 17. uh throughout the night this is a
witness who said throughout the night i
witnessed uh this person insert the same
27 ballots at least five
times should be easy to disprove it
should be easy easy very easy it's not
sure it is easy to disprove yeah
you just go in and look donald trump jr
had a
lunch meeting one time and they talked
about it for three years
right right again the more and more this
stuff stacks up the more and more i
realize
oh there's no convincing the media yeah
there's no comments in the media right
that's what so worries them is the
accountability and when people say why
does the trans thing matter hold on a
second you have someone who might sign
an executive order into action if god
forbid he actually takes office joe
biden that says
uh basically any boy can go into any
locker room he wants
and potentially parents will not be able
to stop their children from puberty
blockers
may actually be guilty of child abuse if
they don't provide puberty blockers for
their children and the media won't hold
his feet to the fire at all
that's why enough that's why it's scary
this is the election is bad
not because the election was stolen that
too but the consequences afterward
because there is no accountability you
think about this for a second at least
there are some checks and balances
right when you have let's if you just
take it with the white house the house
right with three branches of government
okay
you have a balance you have great people
bitched about gridlock what about an
autobahn that's scarier than a gridlock
when you're talking about someone with
the power of the pen who's the president
yeah and someone who has a media and i'm
not just talking about a house or senate
a president a house and the media who
will call them
on nothing that's what's scariest about
this election you see them not calling
them to the mat
on the election itself you think they're
going to do you think they're going to
do that when they go oh my gosh the
science shows us that pumping a young
boy full of estrogen is bad for him
you're never going to bring that up no
and they're claiming right now that
they're going to go after him just as
hard as they went after trump and yeah
it took us days and days of pounding on
the door to get them to ask the question
about packing the court
right like they didn't want to touch
that it took almost a month of them
going
hey he said he's going to ban fracking
you should probably ask him pennsylvania
voters might care about this are you
going to ban fracking well i think their
treatment of obama and uh president
trump is comparable
very very much so yeah snl didn't tell a
joke
for eight years that's their new
strategy though
that's the brand that under obama it's
like every sketch was
it was about obama and it was him
showing up in like now uh as one of the
most successful presidents in
american history there's nothing to rip
him about
[Laughter]
the skinny the skinny fat guy who
changes his accent depending on how
black his audience is despite
the fact that sarah palin would kick his
ass all over the basketball court
there's nothing you can find about
barack obama that's funny
um yeah so listen
but you know what as it relates to joe
biden we'll take their word for it well
i think i think the comedians
actually did come up with a lot of funny
stuff during the obama years
just like yeah it wasn't political right
and they didn't they
felt safe at some level so they didn't
even focus on politics they weren't they
weren't as angry
i think over the past four years we've
seen a very different
reaction but it's again they've yeah
they've never
obviously come here you see two extremes
when barack obama was president you can
watch all the late night shows saturday
night live and there
there were no political jokes really at
all except for every now and then
against joe biden
which will go on right but they were
actually far more creative
in that they focused on non-political
jokes non-political sketches
during that era then when president
trump became uh well the actual
president still is the president despite
what facebook says
um it was only political joke and they
weren't jokes yeah right it was just
jabbing now you can't find or you find
very little i know i'm speaking in a
generality here you find very little
non-political humor and the political is
not humor
so you have two extremes yeah and they
went after sarah palin pretty hard right
they they told political jokes when it
was a republican they didn't like they
went after john mccain pretty hard and
told jokes about him being
old and you know cheryl had a stage show
about george w bush three years after he
was out of office
yeah and then when donald trump comes in
they go well you know what though i mean
at least george w bush wasn't donald
trump
pick the next republican they'll say
well at least donald trump wasn't
insert the name here yeah and i think
that's the most insidious part of this
it's not
just their behavior it's what they're
saying they're doing to the american
people we're going to hold people
accountable when they have no history of
doing so
when it's a view that they agree with
when they agree with the view
they just let it go and so everybody
watching this goes oh well they said
they're going to hold them accountable
they must be doing
it they're not covering any of these
hearings around the country saying
election fraud is happening
so it must not be real must just be
false claims think about this for a
second for the party that claims that we
are anti-science right that we're
really we know that typically speaking
in statistically speaking there have
been studies done on this
that people who lean liberal they tend
to be younger they tend to be
more empathetic or view themselves as
empathetic whereas conservatives
republicans tend to be more logical
that's how they think through problems
it doesn't mean that both are not
important parts of this equation okay
but everything that has proven the
misdeeds of the left if you look at the
topics
that really they've lost ground where
conservatives or even really just the
anti-social justice warriors have made
headway yeah
issues like coronavirus where people are
saying okay you can't keep locking us
down and basically destroy the economy
irreparably in perpetuity
the issue of gender well hold on a
second okay you do have to acknowledge
that there is some biological component
to male or female
the subjects that have been losing
issues for or gun control well really
you have to look at mass shootings are
mostly committed by handguns and they're
committed by people who aren't obeying
law in the first place
these are all topics where science plays
a role
in statistics and verifiable facts that
are not up for debate
play a role we're not talking about well
hold on a second you can look at
different countries and maybe there's a
better way to frame an economy
some economies that have sort of a split
some countries have sort of a split
socialist economy and free enterprise
some of them do better we can look at
the norwegian model but then we have to
look at the quality of life in the
united states how much of it is nature
how much
of it is nurtured those are
conversations to have but the areas that
have exposed the left for their
hypocrisy and the media
is they will not tell you the science
behind puberty blockers
and hormones and cancer they will not
tell you the science
behind the cdc death rates over the
course of the last
decade they will not tell you the
science from johns hopkins university
they will not tell you the science
regarding statistical voting anomalies
they will not tell you the science
regarding graphs and charts coming out
of china
that look like a lying child made them
well their narrative tells them what is
allowed what kind of evidence
is even allowed to be considered and if
no matter what the facts
that you present them are again the
narrative will just it'll just glance
right off yeah
even if it's the same agency they just
quoted like they've been in bed with a
bho from the very beginning and then the
who comes out and says please stop
telling people that lockdowns are a
great way to combat this virus they're
really really bad and it's like
inadmissible w.h.o has gone to the dark
side we'll miss you
no they didn't even report it they
didn't even say anything about it they
just skipped right over it like it never
happened
all right speaking of things that we
can't skip over actually um we
need to uh check in with uh we we do
this every now and then people here in
the
office the edit day with uh people at
work
[Music]
and actually today what we're going to
do before we go in with them um spartan
armor is of course a wonderful sponsor
bulletproof
vests right that we use here we all
usually sometimes you can tell that
we're wearing them sometimes you can't
am i wearing one right now
you don't know yeah you wore one for the
michigan rally that's right
mission rally i was interested in being
a militiamen you look like a rapper but
it's just because just being safe people
kill uh and by the way you can use the
promo code crowder to get 10
off if you go to spartanamersystems.com
and unlike a lot of these places out
there they're actually nij certified
which means that there's
this is kind of the gold standard of
testing a lot of people will say we are
nij
certified equivalent kind of like wait a
second do you actually live
in uh in malibu it's malibu adjacent
where's that
inglewood well that's a little different
it's the equivalent so they're actually
nij
certified and we have a clearance of
this we're going to be testing it today
and uh one of our wonderful interns will
be shooting him even brendan
uh you have your spartan armor vest are
you ready to go sir
good feeling confident okay we are going
to test this in a controlled
no wait hold on a second he's wearing
that one is only nij certified up to uh
pistol that's a pistol that's not a
rifle
angela no we need to switch out for a
pistol could she not can she why is she
not stopping angela angelo
okay so it's very important that you
understand what you need the
certification for
yes some of the vests are up to 44
magnum which is still really impressive
right
like that one they will not handle a
rifle round but they do sell rifle
rounds
different yeah read the descriptions of
the rules i'll go to
the link we'll find somebody to replace
it let's let's really um
let's really frame in the cardioid
pattern to our microphones for the next
little bit
yeah uh again that's spartan armor
systems
uh is it spartanharmoursystems.com and
uh ten percent off if you enter the
promo code card they're shipping really
quickly right now they're one of the few
companies they've worked with us they do
not have delays due to covid
uh let's continue with um some uh
whistleblowers from the postal service
the best among us yes heroes benjamin
gibbert
oh my god here we go send in the postal
workers
[Laughter]
come in for these postal workers are the
best of the best of the best
they're trying to survive in conditions
you couldn't possibly imagine trained to
eat things would make a bill go puke
really they mostly slack off and are
protected by their union well that's
true
that is awesome got us there we only
have overnight shipping because of fedex
they had to ruin it for the rest of us
which line do i stand in i don't
understand i never know what the
possible service
um so this is a there's a product uh
it's called the amistad project um
and they held a press conference so this
is separate from different uh states
i believe this was in pennsylvania about
uh maryland ballot voter fraud this is
specifically coming from
postal workers um what was that it's not
about slaves no it's not about slaves so
much different
they requested is almost on her i'm
thinking amadeus that's the one with the
uh where they're writing the funeral uh
what's the name of a funeral song what
is it called again a dirge not a dirge
another song
there's another word for it i'm not sure
son of a [ __ ] okay
it was mozart in it um the lawyers there
requested logs evidence um
that uh the drop boxes uh uh were
secured they want to check that to make
sure that they were secure you just have
like it has a lock on it you know like
imagine it's a gun in your house imagine
it's important it's been refused though
it has been completely refused um and
these postal workers claim that um
this alone might be caused to undo the
certification this is something that's
important you don't need to prove
millions of fraudulent votes you just
need to
uh you just need to prove that they
weren't safe and secure i would argue an
ethernet cable going straight to
communist china
you know it's a long cable tomato
tomato chai comm they said that this is
enough and i would agree to undo the
official certification of election
results
will they ever release video
of these drop boxes as they promised
so far we have demanded such information
it has been refused
people refuse for a reason
what is that reason we have election
experts that have been working with us
who say
that that conduct and breaking the chain
of custody prevents the certification of
the election process as applied
under federal law the help america vote
act
all right the chain of custody is
important enough
yes okay the chain of custody this is
something that is required legally so
that we know that these ballots aren't
switched you know so someone doesn't
pull an old david copperfield with the
future of the free world
so if let's say a chain of custody
they're bringing in o.j where he was
found guilty known as civil court of
course he
was innocent and uh we all rushed to
judgment on the criminal justice so
sorry of course we were i was that's
true
we were very quick to judge him but the
civil court where he was guilty right
uh and then he went to jail later on
from memorabilia imagine that we have a
chain of custody
and they walk behind i don't know let's
just say a pony wall
oj you see some cops walk him behind the
pony wall they do that little bit where
they walk down the stairs then he comes
up and it's just kevin hart in an orange
jumpsuit you go well on a second that's
not the same thing
there was no one monitoring it like the
chain of custody is that that's what
happened with the balance
what happened is the ballots did not go
through the proper chain of custody for
example in some scenarios where they
said a pipe burst which is not true we
have verifiable video evidence and then
all of a sudden the ballots don't seem
to be the numbers don't reflect
what was statistically a pattern that
was becoming increasingly likely that's
the thing with patterns i know you guys
don't like science so much anymore
leftists but when you see patterns
especially the bigger the number gets
with more votes the more consistent that
pattern
often becomes i'm not an analyst i'm not
a statistician but there are a lot of
people who've made this argument and it
stands to reason again if you were just
to pull this room
how many trump voters probably a hundred
percent you go bigger maybe it's 90.
bigger 80 all of a sudden you have an
entire municipality or state
it's 50 50. those are also by the way
known as bellwether counties of which
donald trump won
19 of 20. oh that seems like a lot and
by the way
this was precluded or preceded by us
saying hey dropboxes are a bad idea can
we at least have some protections to
make sure that they're secure can we at
least have some video things in there oh
no no no this is going to be fine we'll
make sure they're secure we'll make sure
people are watching we'll make sure
there's video evidence
and then nothing right yeah nothing then
somebody had a chain to it like an old
old school criminal stealing an atm yeah
we'll get in eventually
so another postal service worker um had
130 to
280 000 ballots this is what he claims
um and he said that they disappear
uh in his trail i think we have this
clip right now where he says they just
disappeared
um after he was taking them from new
york
to pennsylvania which almost almost
seems like from out of state
this evidence demonstrates and it's
through eyewitness testimony that's been
corroborated
by others through their eyewitness
statements
that 130 000 to 280
000 completed ballots for the twenty
twenty general election
were shipped from bethpage new york
to lancaster pennsylvania where those
ballots
and the trailer in which they were
shipped
disappeared but as things became weirder
i got to thinking and wondered why i was
driving complete ballots
from new york to pennsylvania
it's a little late to be thinking yeah
wow
i didn't know why so i decided to speak
up
and that's what i'm doing today i
believe beyond a shadow of a doubt
we have evidence of a massive transfer
of
of completed curated ballots ready to be
injected into
counting centers and that guy who was
speaking earlier i don't
you know it listen if you're going to
show up and you're going to provide
witness testimony under oath
don't go with the renfield haircut no
it's not a good look
steven this only matters if you think
new york and pennsylvania are different
states
still so you know that's a conspiracy
theory
that's unfounded can i say shitholes
about states
oh yeah that's interesting yeah yeah
maybe not if you're the president
mainly new york mainly new york but
let's be honest philly you got the
liberty bell
not much else yeah and it's on to it
it's broken your state equivalent to a
national food
um really the star player in it is
cheese whiz
yeah with a philly cheese stick because
you haven't lived
do you mean do you mean i like the
sliced beef i'd like to grow the onions
in the peppers
cheese whiz do better philly no whiz
uh by the way everyone watch leave a
comment right now we're testing the
youtube algorithms who do you prefer
who's whose performances do you prefer
elliott or ellen leave that in the
comments and debate amongst yourselves
we'll see if this gets the youtube fact
checking
the comments on fire oh here's the story
i really wanted to cover today
okay this is one that just really uh
gets my goat
oh if i lived in dearborn well yes okay
okay i was wondering
you would protect that goat
my face is just this is this is weighing
on me it's going increasingly from
putting skin to just pudding
covering these hearings that no one in
the media will touch is a pride
swallowing siege
that i will never fully tell you about
but now we move on to covet and cnn and
their flip-flopping i saw this tweet
um we'll get to it in a second from jake
tapper
yeah like they have a scoop breaking
breaking news and i mean i almost like i
almost
i almost just just i just started
cutting myself so i could
no longer be numb
so do you remember that early on we were
talking about how china this is
something we were fact checked and it
was called a conspiracy theory just like
kind of and this is what's going to
happen down the line
unfortunately it may happen after
another president is whisked into office
which
nope not i know everyone says you need
to accept the results i'm probably not
gonna
so i hope it doesn't end up being this i
hope that there's actually investigation
so we don't end up where we
are right now with kovid where early on
we were saying this we were screaming it
from the rooftops we even did a parody
with the kung flu fighting and you named
the people who they now
named that's right didn't talk about
before now
they're admitting that they have the
scoop on cnn that china lied so
let's go back into our time traveling
machine where we were talking about uh
china
being to blame for the coveted pandemic
and how they lied about it here you go
but it did originate in wuhan and there
was a cover-up and china did not
buy us time they did the opposite crazy
president isn't just the blame game and
make no mistake we hold china fully
responsible for concealing the virus
and unleashing it upon the world it
could have stopped it they should have
stopped it
would have been very easy to do at the
source and i got to that clip is really
hard for audio wade to watch
because there's a buzzing at the white
house like just please help
yeah replace your xlr everyone to the
white house
got the budget come on people are gonna
if it's picture just picture give it the
same importance you would a high school
time capsule
this is the leader of the free world
people in silver suits with long v-necks
200 years from now are going to be
pulling up this
clip looking at the leader of the free
world
going oh it seems that their audio
equipment was very rudimentary
[Laughter]
so that's what we said and the president
sent it and of course what did the media
do
they said there was no basis in donald
trump and of course
all of his supporters by proxy uh were
conspiracy theorists and um
they don't say racist they say
xenophobic but you know what tomato you
lie
we had a white house saying china virus
china virus china virus
it wasn't the china virus tying
coronavirus to china and chinese people
isn't just a racist dog whistle
it's a whole racist orchestra trump's
been
tooting his dog whistle pretty hard by
calling it
chinese virus has a catchy little
nickname for the coronavirus he now
calls it
the chinese virus every chance he gets
because you know they say
a great way to prevent a virus from
spreading is to name it something racist
okay uh first off can we pause and go
back to stephen colbert really quickly
oh look at that he has wooden logs
over his wooden log fire
extra locks i don't know how to how
i don't know how to build a fire how am
i going to start this fire we'll put it
over a fire
thank you in turn that works let's make
it look more like a fire yeah let's
let's put the camera and microphone 30
feet away from them
stick some yeah we need space for the
fire and then also here's a blind man
walking still
don't ask questions the focus group said
they liked it
also here's millions of dollars there's
millions of dollars now that's him
trying to find a story the intern put in
the heavy lifting
with the box fire under the fire you're
like ah mr cobart what do you want you
want a box fire do you want a tp i don't
know what that means
that was on cbs but uh i have another
checked account like it's a ballot
machine
so uh this is what went on right of
course you said
china of course obviously they're lying
about the virus they're covering it up
it originates from china donald trump
the reason he kept saying china virus
was because he was trying to cut through
the media saying it has really nothing
to do with china oh we don't know
but now now i scrolled through my
timeline yesterday
and i see jake tapper beaming from ear
to dumb ass
ear talking about how they now have a
scoop
turns out china has been up to some
shenanigans
we have some breaking news
[Laughter]
kill me inside china documents that
reveal the missteps and the chaos of the
chinese government's early response take
me
seriously the documents are from hubei
province home to the city of wuhan
where the pandemic is thought to have
started the show authorities released
misleading public data on the number one
cnn's nick payton walsh is breaking the
story for us right now
china released misleading public data we
were warned about by the president of
the united states alternative media
ignored as we continued to disseminate
said information as solid fact
we now go to trump eight months ago yeah
six months from now
breaking news some ballots may have been
compromised
yeah we'll get to it eventually by the
way china's never done this before they
didn't have a history
somebody's here listen please someone
hire a hitman to murder me so my wife
can get the insurance complaint
i have just when i see this breaking
news
wow i thought the fire on a fire was bad
not only did we make this argument but
do you want to know how even
an 11 month old poll watcher could tell
that china was lying about their deaths
this graph look at this graph that is
the graph that china gave in total
deaths
oh cool that's feasible so they stopped
having deaths in april
they just stopped yeah well no no but no
stop
it was then the same level same number
of people it didn't go down to zero
that's right oh what do we do if we tie
them and go down to zero they're never
gonna believe us again
i don't know keep it at five okay like a
five variation what do we wanna have
margin of error plus we know
just fine
will carry our water american media is
so stupid
and then you remember the stories came
out china has gotten the virus under
control
the united states would act like this
and the the scary thing is people often
reference probably they talk about media
corruption
cnn china didn't just release these i
don't listen
it's like damien you expect damian to be
satan incarnate right you have low
expectations of damien
what i don't expect is the other kid to
start breaking heads off pigeons okay
cnn you reported it as legit we know
that
china specifically the communist chinese
government the people are just as
oppressed by the way
my heart goes out to the chinese people
chinese government
wipe them off the face of the map you
reported it as legitimate
we have no expectations and you know
what this the lesson learned here is
we should have the same expectations of
our media counterparts as we do of the
communist chinese government
the people who ran over folks with tanks
yeah jake tapper you're in good company
breaking news
donald trump no chess china china is
[ __ ] ah
yes ah thank you
through this guy never before seen
footage
hey washington post can we get a
pinocchio on that at least
breaking news think about it but we got
fact-checked by snopes because we said
that it's champ in champaign
uh champagne or sorry cologne germany
cologne germany sorry yeah not champagne
cologne germany different kind of
different
perfume german different i'll get fact
checked thrice nothing yet on jake
tapper no
um in cologne germany they handed out
pamphlets to teach
muslim migrants to not rape we got fact
checked because these were actually
pamphlets that had been around for a
while it was just a reprinting
all right how about we just say breaking
news fact check
no
can we do that last night too much to
ask southern poverty law center i know i
know you're busy
classifying southern baptist as a hate
group can we get any fat check on
breaking news china may have been
misleading
you could make the statement china may
have been misleading
insert blank here like it's a high
school english test and the answer is
correct yes
yeah about anything yeah yeah well yeah
and donald trump is the real anti-press
person not china
right yeah china the uh official the
state state press yeah that's
but again we're talking about things
that would keep people safe every time
if you actually want to talk about
keeping people safe how about at this
point in time
china was lying about the virus the
president said so they called him racist
including the
president-elect according to ap took
their word for it joe biden called him
xenophobic
they said that we were racist conspiracy
theorists at that time donald trump put
a travel ban up
and you guys put more people at risk and
then blame donald trump
yeah and that was the whole point for
them they were trying to blame donald
trump for something that was not his
fault the
the economy was roaring there was
absolutely no way for a democrat to have
a path to the presidency at that time
and this comes along and he says yeah
i'm pissed off too i wish china had done
a better job they're like no no
no mr president they've got it under
control now five deaths we've seen it
every single day it's fantastic you
don't have the same control
well they feel like they're safe now
that they think that they're present at
one
right they can go okay real news they're
trying to actually watch yeah this is
one thing
conservatives republicans are wrong
about this after the election the virus
will go away won't go away until joe
biden's inaugurated they need to they
they understand that most americans
don't keep track of these things they
only
who's in office what's my 401k who's in
office what's my who's in office can i
go outside now
who's in office do i have to freeze in
the cold like muppet christmas carol's
sleeping in the trash can because of
covet and social distance at christmas
in december
in boston right that's what they do so
they're going to keep this as
as stringent they're going to keep it as
much of a violation of your individual
liberties and rights as humanly possible
until you see joe biden waltz on down
those steps as a new president and
kamala harris pushes him down the steps
yeah
and is then oh the new president sorry
the other ankle
over under i guess i say i give it uh
about two months
time's a ticket hope you non-violent
drug offenders enjoy being slave labor
indefinitely oh jeez
um it's like a lifeguard it's like a
lifeguard and some guy's in the water
sees a shark and he's just like yeah but
i don't like you yeah and keeps his
whistle in his pocket
donald trump was going shark shark and
the lifeguard's like yeah
that's a 20-footer call me when it's
call me when it's 30.
i'm speciesist against sharks it's
species these beaches will not shut down
which by the way i am these beaches will
not shut down we're gonna have people
crawling here fourth of july this is the
summer sound see
yes exactly jake tapper is the mayor of
amity
yeah it's like after jaws 3 saying
breaking news there might be sharks in
the water maybe dangerous sharks i don't
know
we'll look into it see this [ __ ]
spill out all over the deck
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a novel virus a what oh
boy uh here's something else that's more
insidious because we can see this now we
can laugh at it because they're stupid
but yeah well what's worse is and most
americans don't pay attention to this is
what
during that period of time exactly what
we're seeing now at the hearings
exactly like we're seeing now with the
evidence being brought forward the
statistical anomalies
the fact that the voting machines and
tabulators were connected
with an ethernet cable it's the stuff
that is
never covered and this was an example we
covered it on this show at that point in
time it's not like this is something new
um this was the head of the world health
organization or the world health
organization a representative speaking
with someone from taiwan completely
uh slam dunking them on the skype call
acting as though they can't even hear
the question
was never covered in media this should
send chills down your spine here
would the who consider taiwan's
membership
i couldn't hear your question okay yeah
let me let me let me repeat the question
no that's okay
let's move to another one then right
because
i'm actually curious on talking about
taiwan as well on taiwan's case
[Music]
you can do that
nothing in the rulebook you can't hang
out says you don't have to answer
any questions or have any accountability
when you're ahead of the leading global
health organization yeah
just imagine all this time when i was in
fox news or we've changed my minds or
actually
people on this show like politicians who
have debated and i just hear something i
don't like or for which i'm ill-prepared
and just go
i didn't hear you well let me repeat it
no
yeah any time kaylee mackinnani doesn't
call on whoever's from cnn or whoever
then ever the press gets like furious
yeah this is totally fine that's the
worst answer in the world too by the way
i didn't hear your question oh i'll
repeat it no no we can move on
like that that tells you that you sound
the question you know what that is
that's someone like in hockey you used
to have people like this who people
didn't like there was a guy like mario
lemire was a player people who know him
again we want to see you commenting here
to see if this helps with the youtube
algorithms because they're screwing with
search results
um allegedly allegedly completely
unfounded baseless allegations but
um mario lemire was one of the best puck
handlers right in the game he was very
very skilled but he was also
boy so he would always look to the ref
for someone to step in like come on you
know these people like oh
foul you don't really get fouls you
can't go out of bounds right that sort
of
remedies itself pretty quickly at least
it did in the 90s that's what you see
with that leader of the world health
organization you only say
i didn't hear the question if you expect
someone else to step in
and to do your work for you there's
there is no point when i would be
sitting
with someone who is taking an
adversarial position in the realm of
political or philosophical debate
where i would ever feel comfortable
saying well i i didn't hear the question
because i know
that would be followed immediately by
let me repeat it right
yeah he didn't think that would happen
because these people aren't used to
being called to the mat ever
this really comes you want to boil this
problem down we're talking about
this election joe biden china the
coronavirus
the track records that biden has had in
67 years in office
fact check that politico although you'll
let jake tapper go on with this breaking
news
kamala harris her track record on
criminal justice all of these
problems um their manifestations of the
same disease and that's a complete
lack of accountability no one calls them
on it
yeah and this was important at the time
because we had taiwanese doctors that
were trying to give data to the world
and say hey here's here's some
information about what's going on with
this virus
and they were rejected right because of
that right so yeah that was
that was the whole thing it wasn't just
her trying to jab taiwan at this guy
they were trying they were trying to
warn china by the way taiwan before that
about how china was lying about
no human human transmission it's like
when you know i don't know if anyone
ever actually still does this anymore
but you put a check
into the atm or you go to the bank you
have to deposit but you didn't put it in
the right way you put money in a vending
machine and they're like hey listen
it actually can be transmitted from
human to human they put it in goes
reject it yeah yeah that's taiwan every
time
with china well yeah well with the world
now and by proxy cnn in the nba
yeah you can't warn people if you don't
exist right oh yeah
that's true it's very hard whatever
happened to being against denying
people's existence
apparently if i say wait hold on a
second ellen ellen page just became
elliot give me a second to get used to
it i'm denying their existence
but when someone says effectively to the
nation of taiwan
um i didn't hear your question and i
won't respond to it
we don't care
[Laughter]
um and of course they they deny these
claims from taiwan why
because they don't recognize them in the
country exactly they do not even
recognize taiwan as a country
because of china china will not allow it
right china will not allow the world
health organization to recognize taiwan
as a country normal disney
right and because the world health
organization is so afraid of china
they're crippled they can't do anything
that was panic in that guy's face
he tried to hide it he hung up yeah yeah
and do you know who else said that uh
you know their reputation is beyond
stellar the world health organization
got no string yeah so you've got saucy
saying world health organization
is uh the most unbelievable uh a global
uh organization
leader every health that we've ever seen
what about johns hopkins screw them they
believe men are men
yeah the experts say the experts say
wait a second hold on a second hey folks
you fought you're an expert right i have
worked in epidemiology my whole life
what
can we bring that back up again that
graph like hey voucher you're an
epidemiologist
what about this graph what happened here
well you know what uh that
nope checks out speaking of a remake of
flatliners yeah exactly
we had this in our song the kung flu
fighting parody remember the
whistleblower
uh it was lee wendy
oh yeah what was the lyric after that uh
he said here come the virus
which we thought was distasteful because
they murdered him
yeah yeah we were like hey we're kind of
worried about the fact that we're making
a joke about this whistleblower who's
disappeared because it said
family will never see it again but we
realize unless we shoehorn that into a
silly parody
you wouldn't know about it nine years
from now jake tapper oh receiving
breaking news go to yourself
no he's gone they claimed it was coveted
it was actually the 17 bullets that
killed him
we believe it was apparently uh it's not
about aerosol
particles or airborne particles but nine
millimeter luger
everybody was kung flu fighting yes we
can in fact confirm
that 45 acp cannot fit through a mesh
net
mask didn't do them any good even with a
charcoal filter
it doesn't matter when they're
disappearing you because it's a
communist regime and imagine this this
is something
remember hong kong the protesters they
were singing the national anthem that
brought a tear to my eye when i was
watching it the american nationalist yes
the american nationalism
yeah yeah no that's clear that's the
only natural matters
yeah the norwegian national anthem
sounds remarkably like jingle bells
like deck the halls
[Music]
it's a christmasy kind of place there's
an economy we should emulate thanks
bernie it's always snowing it makes it
festive the north the norwegian
socialism what have they brought us
strongmen and uh
elevator music all right don't wait up
so
it brought a tear to my eye because
people in hong kong know that their only
hope and this is something that people
don't believe i just bit my tongue
that's hurt
my mouth gets dry when i'm doing this
show and i haven't been able to drink
any water
but um their only hope is the united
states of america
just like when when people across the
globe are talking about free speech and
willing to fight for free speech whether
they're in australia whether they're the
uk
whether they're in canada by the way and
you can drive there in 20 you could
throw a baseball there
if you live in upstate new york their
only hope is the united states because
it's the only place
where it exists right when hong kong is
singing the american national anthem and
they're saying
we have to fight back against an
authoritarian regime
who lies and murders its own citizens
they say hey look america we need you
we're singing your anthem
we're waiting for that air support to
come in just like we were fighting the
axes of evil people going please come on
we're waiting for the red white and blue
so we can get this thing over with
and then they tune it in to cnn because
i don't know maybe they're at an airport
layover in charlotte
and they hear jake tapper saying nothing
to see here china's on the up and up
do you have any idea how soul crushing
that must be
for people looking they're looking to
the shining city on a hill
and oh [ __ ] that light's gone out
because cnn decided it wasn't worth
covering
except in nine years breaking but they
already starved to death
kind of like when sean penn went up with
his silly little crocodile tears saying
the way that they
star and smear a wonderful leader
in chavez and venezuela how many people
do you think
that killed how many people do you think
died because the american media didn't
hold anyone's feet to the fire
and couldn't cover the fact that people
were being starved to
death because it was the net result of a
policy that you go on
and support and argue for day in and day
out those people in hong kong sing the
national anthem
you are breaking their hearts you are
breaking their hearts and several of
them have already disappeared
between the time they sang that anthem
and you decided you had your breaking
story tapper you
hack yeah because they they know that
this is the only place where free speech
is not something they have to talk about
in the past tense
right it's something that exists now and
they know that it's worth fighting for
and if our side knows that it's worth
fighting for then we have a battle ahead
of us
because because yeah it this is the
battle line it is unbelievable to me and
the media doesn't even cover they just
they just destroy the lab
in wuhan that's what china did yeah they
just destroy like these these are things
that can be verified
right people don't understand the
response when you say hey words matter
this is what they say right
pronouns he his hers we're going to ban
you because
you're saying that ellen page doesn't
have an uh that eliot page doesn't have
an imdb
credit to his name he doesn't
he doesn't no character breakdown for
which ellen page was hired said
must have [ __ ] that didn't exist that's
not hate speech
and it won't be accused of being
retroactively guilty of it along with
every single hollywood liberal who
worked
with ellen page i'm getting confused
myself i almost said elliot i see
yeah but you know what words do matter
they do
carry some weight and certainly so
should a free press
but this is what's crazy when we talk
about freedom of speech right we've
talked about that well freedom of speech
doesn't mean it doesn't
doesn't exist as people know it anymore
because it's not about the government
infringing on freedom of speech if the
town square is entirely run by two
or three or four companies and that's
what we are reaching first amendment but
we're also talking about a free press
it doesn't exist anymore if the free
press is
actually beholden to foreign interests
of communist chinese governments
and will allow countless people to
suffer needlessly
and die because they can't offend the
people who butter their bread that's
where we are in the united states of
america you may be going listen this
sounds too extreme
how could jake tapper and everyone at
cnn say nothing was going on
in china and now just say breaking news
they're not that stupid or at least they
don't think
we are actually you're incorrect on both
counts and more importantly
you do have to look and follow where the
money comes from this is important we
are the shining city on a hill
we were that shining city on a hill and
what happened with hong kong they were
looking to us
and they saw someone put that light out
like an old lantern worker in a dickens
novel
and this is what's happening right now
across the world with people who are
hope they go god
listen people we haven't seen a free and
fair election in a century
but the united states we're waiting on
that cat we're waiting on that uh on
that uh
cavalry coming over the hill yeah and it
may never come so exactly what happened
with wuhan exactly what happened with
the coronavirus right we now have that
time span nine or six months whatever it
was
don't let that happen right now with
election fraud for people out there who
go oh i don't think that we're going to
win this and why don't you get off this
topic because it seems like it's
inevitable
because people die and i'm not just
talking about the united states i'm
talking about people
across the world when people talk about
freedom
when people talk about the ability to to
peaceably assemble what do you think
happens we're just talking about that
peaceably assembled you have them
you have americans saying well do you
really american pastor saying do you
really need to go to church for the
first amendment
what do you think is happening when you
have countries where people are
burned alive largely muslim countries
for owning a bible
they go what what we own a bible but
come on it's the 21st century right
look to the united states and they point
and they see rob bell going we don't
need churches or bibles to be christians
come on you want to remove all hope from
these people
your words do carry some weight we do
have responsibility as americans and i
get that this is we want to destroy all
of our traditions and our social norms
in the united states of america because
the left wants us to be more like these
other countries
who are looking to us as an example who
are looking to
us for inspiration but i guess that
doesn't really matter oh
breaking news cnn doesn't give a [ __ ]
nor does youtube so youtube right now
we're gonna go have some fun on mug club
livewithcredit.com but right now
you can go just you know what you know
the rest